all right let's put a little positivity
in our life today i mean it's about
just a little bit of positivity in our
life today
hi it's me thomas and also i'm off today
i'm gonna watch some football
and also go cowboys and vikings
and uh friday is the 11th which is my
anniversary and it's also brenda lee's
birthday
and speaking that if you are hearing
this brenda lee it's this
around my store everyone in the store
including you brenda lee has to wear a
face covering
who's pregnant has to cover the nose and
mouth
it was like this the whole year brenda
lee and that will be it
no mask no shopping trip friendly
no mask no shopping trip
face coverings have to be worn inside
the grocery store for this year
yes [ __ ] you gavin newsom
and also yes
and i think like uh
i might order takeout on december 11th
which is my anniversary i think i might
do that yes
i think i might and also uh what else am
i gonna say oh yeah
but remember normally on the radio
station we play like
huey lewis nice and duran duran
all right but we'll be back to those
kind of music yes we'll be we'll be back
to that stuff
december 26th the day after christmas
then normal music comes back not
necessarily i find that they play
christmas music through january 1st am i
the only one that notices that
i know well towards like the one week
before
christmas it's gonna start getting busy
i'm pretty sure it is
and um is there anything else i'm gonna
say oh yeah i guess it's about it so i
guess i'm going so i gotta go so bye
bye
bye thomas bye mr murphy
hi it's me thomas and today is mark's
the anniversary that nelson mandela died
in 2013 at the at the age of 95 years
old and i was mad that he died
i wanted him to live to 100 years old
but me it's because of his health
that didn't his age but nelson mandela
did die that it's true
but um not before playing lucius fox
in the dark knight um not before
being in the shawshank redemption
so you know at least he got those bruce
almighty at least he got those things
out of the way before he passed away so
you know f in the chat for nelson
mandela one of our best actors of our
time
that tim that made him die his health
maybe yes at the age of 95 listen to me
it's time for him to go if you're
covered up you might your
your microphone by the way thomas time
for him
to go meaning yeah it is time
for him to go what that man did
but enough about this i'm gonna think
that like today is a john zesnick's
birthday from
the band google dolls and he's better
than tara swift
yeah i think we all agree even if you
don't like google dolls you would have
to agree here right
it is rock google dolls
because i don't have him on my playlist
if i have pandora yes john zesnick
no adele taylor swift or megan trainer
all rock music mm-hmm i would
no it's true everyone thinks people
don't understand this and
and david p is right there's there's
okay so like a lot of people think that
nelson mandela died vanessa mandela is
actually alive and
it's called the freeman effect okay
it's called the freeman effect um you
can look it up
guys look i'm not gonna bog you down
with too much scientifical you know
nonsense
but it's very interesting and i did the
video about home alone like the segments
of that
but i didn't do the whole thing because
that'll get a copyright
good call thomas you don't want your
stream to be suspended
because you've seen like how the
airliner works yes
that's how it works yes but i might
watch home alone too yes
they go to miami that's where the super
bowl was held in miami this year
the niners which um i care about the
cowboys but
my mom likes the niners they lost
to the kansas city chiefs
chiefs win the super bowl this year
but the next one will be in tampa it
will
tampa florida
and i got some christmas cards for my
new sister sierra
and kaylee who was a cousin yes nice i
did
i went to the dollar store for that it's
not a bad deal
no it's not and i
uh never mind uh oh
thomas censored himself what was he
gonna say
what was he he censored himself what was
he going to say
and i uh never mind
oh boy oh boy
was he gonna get racist now the guessing
is worse because now
no matter what we guess is gonna be
worse than what he's actually gonna do
but i think i know like i'm gonna watch
some football tomorrow
and i have a feeling that your dreads
are gonna lose all 16 games
and they're going to like zero 16
just like the cleveland browns and the
detroit lions
so i guess we're going so i go so bye
bye wow that wasn't a very aggressive
buy that he's he's holding
he's holding in the the anger that's
what it is and i understand that
i really do i think beef drew's right
he's going to call the federal he's
going to call it the banking system in
the federal reserve and that's not what
you want thomas
not this close to the holidays hi it's
me thomas and also
today or actually yesterday was day uh
david lander died
oh i just remember him from lego island
as the villain guy
bomb tool for legos i'm 30 years old
mm-hmm thomas
you're 36 years old
and also oh yeah today is larry bird's
birthday he is 64 years old
he is and also yes
i think i've seen that in atlanta
georgia the tower crane
downtown i think it's used for building
stuff the tower
crane it does move yes
and uh oh yeah i'm gonna give my new
sister
the christmas cards and i said next year
we were sitting inside the tables eating
out out at a restaurant
on my birthday july 29th with kevin and
my new sister sierra and they'll sing
happy birthday to me happy birthday
thomas but i hope she wears a black
dress
on why that's what i'm hoping for that
so i guess i'm going so i gotta go so
bye
bye short update not all of them are
gonna be hey not all of them are gonna
be bangers you gotta make some ballots
sometimes
you know how that goes
hi it's me thomas and today is andy
williams birthday but he's not alive no
more i really like that guy i really did
he always sings the christmas stuff he
would have been uh
93 years old i like that guy i really
did
this is my out of all my thomas faces
this is my favorite thomas face
this is my favorite thomas face
look at that look at that fella right
[Music]
there
and also it's today i'm thinking yes
today is julian moore's birthday and she
is six years old for the movie kingsman
as the villain yes
i mean i would think that she did other
roles that are more memorable than in
kingsman but okay
now 60 and daryl hannah also 60
splash oh you have tom hanks yes
and also uh what else am i asking oh
yeah
i'm guessing yes i will watch home alone
tomorrow
when i get off work yes and i'll pause
like the stuff like i'll tell you like
the one thing you should never do yes
right
cause i already did my video about like
christmas yes
there's a lot of birthdays how so i
guess we're going somewhere
badly would you want thomas to do an
entire director's commentary of home
alone too
the entire director's commentary is just
thomas
doing things like this
right
that's kind of rude yes it's me thomas
i'm videotaping this right here
the behavior yes i'm honoring it's just
amazing
that is kind of rude we said
thomas is not [ __ ] happy at that rude
airport shuttle driver and i don't blame
him
you see that guy who said that can't
like beat it
that is rude to that person you don't
ever do that
if i said that dude okay you know what
that's rude
i want to speak to your supervisor for
what you did that's rude
i would definitely say that yes i want
to speak to your supervisor for what you
did to me
because that's uncalled for it it's rude
did you hear that that's me thomas we
don't ever do that here
now film like something like uh the
scene like
planes in the air i'll pause it
okay now they're born a plane yes okay
i'll show you what
they do right here this is amazing
the jail wait you don't hide in hello
you always say
hello to the flight attendants because
if you don't it's rude
yes remember it's on to flight attendant
that's why he has this obsession with
flight attendants and you don't want to
do this
abuse the flight attendant call button
because that's not good
because you know what that's for right
the flight attendant call button
i'll pause right the plane is like going
fast
taking off
and you saw a plane going fast taking
off right i did i did so i think i'll
show you like
i think it's what makes it go with the
aircraft
i think it's what makes it go yes yes
it is sure is thomas no it sure is it's
called
not the is that kat
von d is that the tattoo girl is that
is he has a poster of her in his room
he has a is a poster of her in his in
his room
huh thomas has a type obviously
bro no run way the runway
going fast departing yes
runway
[Music]
push back it's a nice nice uh 20 inch
sony tv though
they do the pushback first engine
starting up yes
that's how it works yes
and i'll pause the video right here
okay here's where the plane's in the air
they have the seat belt barbara go how
do you find these people he would love
getting together with dayton they could
have hangouts
if you if you ever
ever imply that thomas should be with
that
piece of [ __ ] monster dayton thomas is a
pure soul
thomas murphy is a pure soul very very
lovely boy who's working on his life and
dayton hypernova would bring him down
i want dayton hyper to stay [ __ ]
millions of miles away from him
i don't want these two to ever even be
near each other
sign on yes so you don't use the
bathroom during takeoff
so that's not right during takeoff
i think it's what the captain decides
yes the captain
flight attendant
that's that's how it works on boarding
airlines yes
you always say thank you when they gave
you their food i don't
because if you ever had airline food but
seriously folks hey what's the deal with
airline food
hey what's up with the black box why
don't they just make the whole plane out
of it
yeah what are you talking about you walk
into an airplane oh my god like who's
seat's a floatation advice who's that
for you're gonna die if he lands in the
water
sorry
look man it's 20 20. this year's
terrible the last the imagine right
before the end of the year airplane
jokes make a big comeback that's the
last thing we need in this year folks
it's the [ __ ] last thing we need
because that's nice
airline etiquette yes
there so that's the airline yes
going fast i think it's called take off
i love and i mean this sincerely this
isn't me being ironic i love the fact
that thomas murphy
is doing a little mini riff tracks a
little mini mystery science theater 3000
little mini director's commentary of
home alone 2. and what he's focused on
is the airplane in the movie
that's his focus is the airplane
not the plot of the movie not anything
his favorite scenes of the movie i'm
getting on the airplane shuttle
and then being on the airplane this is
why i like thomas he knows what he likes
and he doesn't apologize for it
so i showed you like how it's done like
for this
see that's how it makes it go i think
he's right that's what makes the
airliner go
the captain's right there first officer
yes
the co-pilot that's ways to go like this
and when it's in the air they always put
the landing gear up it's like this
like this sorry sorry right there
right here like this landing gear up
yes because you don't need it down yes
they always put the landing gear up
because it creates drag for the airliner
that's how it works the airlines
but when they come to close landing what
they do is this
remember we're reviewing hollywood don't
forget okay for those of you and
two thousand five hundred
one thousand five hundred
and when the plane lands it's like this
yep that's me to stop yes mm-hmm
how airlines are go yes mm-hmm
they always have the seat belt sign on
yes it's not a joke
but when the plane's like this taking
off
i don't think it's a good time to use
bathroom because that will get you
kicked off the airliner
yes and you don't want that
no refunds no refunds the captain
decides who gets stay
no refunds i think it's right yes
the captain yes has like the stripes on
the
on the uniforms yes because they have
families there too yes
and you never want to try and open the
emergency exit when the plane's in the
air yes
because yeah they'll stop you because
there's it's pressurized
the captain the cabin is pressurized
home alone 2 folks
the commentary you never knew you needed
until now
and the one thing you should never do is
like never drink too much on board the
airliner because the airline
like the air cycle is like circling and
it's really dry in there
it's best to drink water yes
and also move around and also the i
think the laboratories are really small
yes there's bathrooms on there yes
but speaking of bathrooms you gotta be
right home alone too is known for the
airplane scenes everybody knows
that's how i remember the movie the
bathroom before you get on the plane
not during takeoff and landing mm-hmm
could be a flight attendant
so going fast i think it's called the
runway
so i'm gonna go i will join my movies so
i'll upload this video right now so
bye bye thank you thomas thank you so
much
we've learned so much today my airplane
etiquette's gonna be completely
different than before